Nói 153 năm 2018, công an phường tình quyền với hợp với các đơn vị nghiệp vụ thuộc công an thành phố
chỉ mấy lấy lời khai của các nền chứng. Chị xuất camera sắc định những giảm ối tượng
thực hiện hành vi sách hại cụ bà tảm ối tội, tại các nhà thuộc khu phổ in hơn năm và tổ chức
truyết sế như cạnh. Tông tin bà đầu và sáng cùng ngày, người nhà thấy cụ bà năm bất động trên
chế về sép trong nhà, TV vẫn mở nữ định kinh chả thị phát hiện cụ đã từ vong vẫn nghĩ
sâu cụ bà lớn tuổi ninh mất. Tuy nhiên, khi kinh chả camera sắc định giữa bà cụ mất
để làm tăng lễ thị người nhà hỏng hốt khi thấy cụ không từ vong bộ cách bình thường,
mà bị sất hại. Theo camera ghi lại khoảng 184 phụng qua, cụ bà năm 2020
xếp xe TV thì có một đối tượng năng đử mũ, mặc áo khoa, quần lửa lần vào nhà.
Lối tượng sự dụng khối đẻ lên mặt cụ cụ bà cho đến khi cụ mất động.
Sau khi về an, đối tượng nãy nhìn trong bỏ đi. Kinh chả lại tại sản trong nhà, những người sống tại đây cho hai không mất tử gì.
Hịt bố viết đang đường đử trà làm sống.